that's making me a little bit upset
fantastic incredible man it's the owners
of that business it's really simple
joke i don't think anyone can believe it
one of the things that people don't know
about you is just the scale of your
business portfolio it's quite honestly
mental the only thing you can ever do in
life is work as hard as you possibly can
and never give in
what is the cost i basically collapsed
the floor another fit i went to
hospitality checks and then found that i
needed to slow down a little bit and i'd
stop doing the things that kept me well
and i just run myself into the ground so
i knew that that point then i needed to
see something
manchester united are failing i do feel
sorry for the current players and that
won't go down well with a lot of
manchester united fans these players go
out onto the pitch now they feel alone
but that's where i am a little bit
critical of cristiano you're the star
now's not time for throwing your arms
around now's the time to make sure you
lead those people resilience and
robustness and hard work can be taught
and learnt i don't think it's something
you're born with the minute i joined at
11 to the minute i left at 36 manchester
united got everything out of me
everything
of all the people i always talk about
having the influence on my life i never
mentioned my mum and her mum and dad
they're far better people than i am
that's making a little bit upset
[Music]
so without further ado
i'm stephen butler and this is the diary
of a ceo i hope nobody's listening but
if you are then please keep this
yourself
[Music]
we are a normal working-class family
there are no famous sporting ancestors
in our in our family yet somehow we want
to combine 218 caps for our country at
football and netball between us tracy
neville mbu my sister went twice to the
commonwealth games and world
championships representing england 74
times and coached the national team
how and why is that possible that three
siblings in a family reach sport
sporting greatness when there isn't a
long lineage of
you know the granddad was at manchester
united this person was at this club and
they opened doors for me
i don't know really i mean
i'll start at the end because i was
having a conversation yesterday about um
it was actually how long
should you take off after you've had a
baby as a couple whether it be the the
man or the woman
and i was thinking about my sister and
she took like two or three weeks off and
then she was back at it
and
also
my father passed away seven years ago
and on the morning of his funeral i went
and presented
our projects at michael's at a council
meeting and then went and got ready at
home and went to his funeral straight
after it
and
someone said to me it's not normal that
and my sister
my dad passed away in australia whilst
he was while he was watching my sister
play for the commonwealth games
and me and my brother flew straight over
there
my sister
was still coaching the team she never
broke stride and
he was on a ventilator keeping him alive
even though he'd actually to be fair
passed away and they were just waiting
for us to get over
the day after we got there
my sister said i've got a game tomorrow
we can't pronounce that he's actually
dead until after i finish the game i
come back to the hospital
and when i think of that
that's the end i suppose in terms of
that sort of that feeling of just that
drive that commitment to what we do
people say it's not normal someone said
to me it's not normal that that we would
continue our lives irrespective of and
that probably came from my dad and from
a mum
but i think of it is in different layers
for me personally i don't know what it
was like for my sister or my brother but
for me personally i think of it as being
the first layer was my mum and dad their
love for sport that commitment to get
there early to do things my dads used to
say get up early get there early get
your job done
and then when i got to united i'm hit by
nobby styles brian kidd you know
manchester united's european cup winners
in 1968 and then eric harrison a
northern tough yorkshire man who every
single day
drilled us about what it was to be a
manchester united player and then you're
exposed to sir alex ferguson and roy
keane and peter schmeichel and mark
hughes so these different layers
of you know monstrous mentalities of
people who are just massive leaders
we've been exposed to them i was exposed
to them
and that's why i always say that
resilience and robustness and hard work
can be taught and learnt i don't think
it's something you're born with
and i think when you say like how do we
achieve that i just think we're very
fortunate with our parents and the
exposure that we had to brilliant
leaders throughout our career and
examples and the standard bearers that
were next to us
learning through words those words that
your dad would say to you about getting
up and getting at it every morning is a
great way to learn but actions i think
in hindsight seem to be
the best way to
to really learn those lessons
vicariously from observing our parents
and how they're behaving in their lives
i know i'll never forget the day that i
saw my mum my mom stopped coming home
and then i asked my dad where she was
and she said oh she sleeps in the back
of the shop now this corner shop she was
running and then going there and seeing
this bag of rice that she was sleeping
on that had all these rat holes in it
from where the mice and rats had been
eating it that visual of that she was
working that hard even though she didn't
have to to support our family so that
she was sleeping in the back room every
night and not coming home was was a
lesson that i learned without her saying
a word yeah what are the lessons that
you learned from your because you cited
your dad there
as being pretty
um a pretty go-get-em person
how was he functioning and
professionally that taught you these
lessons
he was a lorry driver and he basically
worked for constellation luggage which
was just luggage you know suitcases and
he had to do three drops a week at
daventry which is south of birmingham
and he each had to get them there
basically by the end of monday wednesday
and friday
but we had we lived in a two-two-down
terraced house
and every time my dad got up you can
hear your dad get up when you're young
you just you just hear it because it's
obviously that you know the lights come
on and you hear the sort of noise the
floorboards are creaking
and
we always get up early as a family
anyway but before five o'clock
you'd hear my dad we lived in the back
we were in the back bedroom and he's
he's lorry his wagon was parked at the
back when he was doing to do a drop the
next day
and he'd leave at four or five o'clock
in the morning
on the monday wednesday and friday he'd
take the suitcases he'd wait for the
depot to open at seven eight o'clock
drop them off and he'd be back and have
his job done by eleven o'clock and then
he'd start to go and do his what would
be his commercial work the fundraising
for testimonials the thing that he loved
for say for instance lancashire county
curricular players that was his passion
that's how he got into berry football
club as a commercial director and into
because he had he had a sales mentality
my dad but in the he get his his main
job done by 11 o'clock every single
morning he'd be daventry and back in a
lorry and then after school he'd take us
to football and he'd take us to qriket
so the amount he fit into a day was
unbelievable you know he almost do two
jobs he'd do his job which was his main
job which was earning him his money
which was a lorry driver he'd then come
and do the job which would be
potentially could he do some sort of
like side job selling for like
lancashire country club or the green
mountain cricket club he did he
organized dinners and events and things
like that and then his family would come
after school where he'd put them into
sport would go to united in the evening
i would go um we were at united from 11
11
monday and thursday night so this
constant drive of trying to fit as much
as you possibly can in the day and
that's where i sort of the attack the
day was from my dad get up get there
early let's make sure we're there even
at united we get there early on saturday
there would never be any risk with time
of being late
i feel sometimes that that is a good
thing it's put that into us but
sometimes to live by that now
particularly at the age i'm at sometimes
you sort of think
it's hard to keep yeah it's hard to keep
on doing it and you wonder now
particularly what we know now whether
it's the right i think my dad had heart
problems at a very early age at the age
of 42. you know he's a lorry driver you
know he liked to go for a beer
he liked a night out he did too much he
got stressed
all the things that
i did
so he thinks there's a lot i can see him
without of me
but i don't think i can change it really
what is the cost because for everyone's
i sat here with tim grover who actually
coaches a lot of the young united
players now yeah coach michael jordan
and um kobe bryant for a span of 15
years he was the best soul coach and he
said for everyone's greatness the thing
that causes their greatness in your case
you know that drive and that
ruthlessness and that dedication caused
you to become a manchester united legend
and all these other things but what is
the cost on the other side that people
don't don't see from he he referred to
it as we have our light side and we have
our dark side the dark side is a
consequence an
unavoidable consequence of the light
side yeah what was that dark side for
you and your dad
um
health i think
and i've seen that in the last couple
years with myself i think um
physical health no
i've had i i i
i've said this to be fair on something
that i've done myself in last week on
the overlap
um
i actually to be fair um
raheem sterling scored the goal
in the
uh
european championships against germany a
year and a half ago
and i basically collapsed the floor and
had a fit
and after that
i went to hospital i had checks and then
found that you know i need to slow down
a little bit basically and it's similar
things to what my dad was told in his
40s
that you know ultimately i do too much i
think too much i need to relax more
you know to be fair my wife says it
quite often
you're here but you're not present
do you get that oh my god
so and justin who's interested i'll do
an interview the
uh
other
day
with jeff shreve jeff known me 15 20
years
and he said the problem is when asking
you a question
you've got my question inside the first
two seconds let's say it's a ten second
question you've got my question inside
the first two seconds the next eight
seconds you're thinking about what
you're doing after i can see it in your
eyes already and he's right
so
even during this interview i'm speaking
and sometimes i lose my way in an
interview and i actually forget what the
question was and quite often i'll say
what was the question if i'm on stage
doing like a q a what did you actually
ask me because i've actually drifted off
whilst i'm answering the question into
something that i need to do later and
it's i'm never present so the
consequence is that maybe
i remember sir alex saying to me mrs
children growing up i am missing my
children growing up that's a consequence
of my life i've been in london for four
days
you know but
what can i do i've got i come down to
brentford manchester united i then stay
down sunday because i can't get trained
back trains there's a train strike and
then i'm down doing monday night
football and i'll go back today last
week i was down for another four days
but it's what i do i love what i do i
wouldn't change it but this afternoon
i'll get back to manchester i've got
meetings till six and then tomorrow i'm
full all day thursday i'm in glasgow
doing a dinner with sir alex ferguson so
it is a constant sort of every single
day that i feel like i'm filling days
with things that i love and want to do
but then you say to yourself you do have
those odd moments more now why am i
doing all this
why are you doing this now
you love doing it maybe you know it's
what you enjoy but you sometimes have
those moments don't you wait i have more
of those moments i think why am i doing
those why have i got two hotels why have
i got a football club why have i got a
university why have i built an overlap
shell i'm already on sky why am i doing
these things but it's it's that idea of
i suppose
cramming as much into your life as
possible thinking you've just only got
this sort of short period of time
and
brian kids used to say to us get your
pace early you can't make it up at the
end and we used to sprint
and sprint in our runs and sprint
and that mean if you collapsed at the
end and you didn't quite finish it or
whatever it's better than managing
yourself and thinking i'll save a little
bit we i have to say the players that i
played with at manchester united we
never saved anything it was all left out
there on the pitch
and i think that's how our lives are
since as well we just leave everything
out there on the pitch there's nothing
saved so we just stand up
i suppose saturating every single second
of every single day
i used to think that i was driven i used
to think that you know and that sounds
like a very good framing i'm driven i'm
motivated i thought that's what was
because you said why am i doing this
after i do this podcast there's maybe
you know 10 other companies that i'm
running i have zero time in the day and
then i try and cram in my girlfriend and
my family and do a very bad job of that
i used to think it's because i'm driven
and i'm just whatever and then i asked
myself a question which when i met eddie
hannah i saw the same thing i mean his
book is called relentless yeah are we
really driven or are we being
voluntarily driven as in we're making
the choice to drive towards something or
are we being involuntarily dragged by
some kind of insecurity or some kind of
discomfort with
the prospect of not being busy because
for me i'm convinced these days that i'm
probably being dragged by an insecurity
maybe
but i developed a very young age yeah
maybe i'm not sure i don't know i don't
could you stop i don't feel uh
not sure because this idea that you know
if you stop
it'll kill you and all that sort of
stuff slow down i do feel like i need to
slow down i read a book i think i can't
but it was a few a couple years ago
where it talks about you can never
really retire if you love work and you
are relentless but what you can have is
many retirements during the year and
that's what i've tried to do i don't do
it very well so for instance this
weekend i'm going to spain friday till
monday morning
i caught that's like a mini retirement
so that's a weekend it's a weekend it's
a mini retirement it's where i basically
can say for three days i'm there and um
i'm basically taking a you know i don't
think about work now i will but
and sometimes one of my best my best
ideas come when i'm on those types of
trips but then in six weeks i'll have
another mini retirement for five days or
four days rather than thinking you're
gonna stop for six months and sort of
have a sabbatical that's not probably
gonna happen with people like you or i
because we just basically don't work
that way so to have lots of mini
retirements during the year is what i've
tried to do in the last few years i'm
not sure i'm doing it very successfully
i'm not sure what's wrong with us if
that's what you're asking is there
something wrong with it i don't feel
insecure or vulnerable i don't feel
insecure or vulnerable at all i feel
i feel i feel so confident and i feel
not confident i feel like i've got
coping mechanisms to be able to deal
with things so there isn't any criticism
there's very very little criticism that
i receive now that even touches the
sides of me and i get criticized heavily
on social media through my football
punditry my opinions whatever it may be
because what i went through at united
losing that confidence at the age of 24
paul's treble
going through that difficult patch where
i didn't want the ball seeing the
psychiatrist on my own all the doctor
knew not talking about it till i was 35
but what that psychiatrist gave me was
coping mechanisms and perspective
and i just asked you know if i go
through a difficult moment now
i asked myself the question will i come
out of it to the side did i expect every
day to be a good day
no i don't expect every day to be a good
day so when the bad day comes and it's a
really bad experience or you ever make a
bad business decision did you think
you'd make every decision would be a
good decision in business no it wouldn't
be good you're not going to make the
right decision every single day you're
going to have bad decisions bad choices
bad days so when they come now i can put
them into perspective and move on really
comfortably
so
i feel like i'm i don't feel vulnerable
or insecure
and i'm not quite sure sometimes you
know people say i've got a strategy i've
got a plan
i'm not quite sure any of us have really
because the relative is we don't know
what door's going to open next you don't
know six years ago five years ago that
dragon's den is going to come a knock on
your door you don't know that you
haven't got a clue or 10 years ago
certainly you don't know that's going to
happen in your life but when the knock
on the door comes you think
i fancy walking through that door
and probably the same with me when
things have happened in my life where i
thought i didn't expect that to come
yeah i'll take that
so
we are probably being dragged it's a
little bit like jumping off you go
skiing you have to sort of go off the
sort of black slope
using there's no way out but you're
going down you can't stop and it's a
little bit like you know i feel like to
be fair my life's a little bit like a
black skull a black sloping skiing
i've gone over the edge i've started
what can i do now slow down say to my
businesses say to the teams that i work
with sorry i don't fancy this anymore
well thanks for that but you've we're
here still what what's that i've got no
choice
i've got no choice you've got no choice
we're in do you know why
um i read this book called the body
holds the score and i was actually
speaking to one of my best friends
yesterday who was a extreme workaholic
and then he started having panic attacks
he ends up in hospital and he said to me
he said i felt fine
but the body goes gives out first the
body will you know when the mind is
telling you no you can cope with this
you're doing fine the body will show you
in a pretty um yeah drastic fashion that
you're not okay and that you need to
listen to it to yourself
ever since you you collapsed on that day
have you made
changes honestly
because i'm gonna ask i'm gonna ask you
i'm gonna ask emma
i did
i did i
have i think
but then it's the actual state it's
sustaining the changes and not dipping
back into your old habits
that's the problem
that's what do i do i train four or five
times a week i wasn't always training
pre that
um i try
i've got a sleep ring
and it focuses me more on the time i
need to sleep at night and but then
i don't always wear it now you know it's
a couple of years later it's in my bag
it's here i didn't wear it last night
and i'm annoyed with myself because i
didn't wear it last night i forgot to
put it on when i got back
so habits really that sort of do you
drift back into your old habits um i try
not to pick my phone up when i first
wake up but i'm failing miserably at
that
i'm fairly miserable but i have to take
an email off my phone i've taken
whatsapp off my phone
because they're things that i think work
emails if i think if you wake up to an
email
at four in the morning that's an email
that's not a great email let's say it's
something that you think i've got to
deal with that you aren't getting back
to sleep so i've taken email off my
phone it's only on my ipad it helps
whatsapp i mean what's up announced last
week that they were going to sort of
this idea that you couldn't um you
couldn't be joined in groups and people
didn't know when you were online
i just felt like it was an intrusion
whatsapp i felt like people were
attacking me a constant attack of added
to groups and they see that i'm online
and things like that
oh no
get off
get away from me so i just do imessage
now um
and i say to people ring me
so there have been changes that i've
made that are helpful
because i do feel email is
i love speaking to people so i lived in
a dressing room where the camaraderie
when you email each other at manchester
united charlotte's ferguson didn't email
me we had a brilliant team spirit in the
club we were there every single day we
spoke to each other we socialized with
each other we'd help each other we knew
each other and that's how you build a
team spirit and i felt sometimes email
can be i know it needs to happen in
businesses i know that you need to see
attachments i know you need to
communicate with each other i do believe
that they can be quite damaging to
culture sometimes particularly if
the wrong tony on the i think you can be
misunderstood on email i think it can
come across harsh and they can put
pressure on people and i realize that
the first five years out of football i
was emailing people five six o'clock in
the morning
but you imagine you know you emailing
people at five six o'clock in the
morning the impact that's going to have
on them when they wake up
i've got to deal with that i've got to
email them back it's like that's not
fair it's not right so i have made quite
a few changes but probably not enough
yeah i i completely agree i don't i'll
be on people this will surprise people i
look at my emails once a week
so my assistant looks at my inbox and
then if there's she puts them on my list
and then i go to my list when i'm ready
yeah and also with all my whatsapps and
all that stuff all notifications off and
it's just for me trying to take back
control of my time so i choose when i go
to it it doesn't notify me that it needs
me now and i used to have email dread
yeah you know early mornings especially
you're running a big company you've got
600 employees or more yeah
there's always going to be something
wrong there is yeah and it doesn't care
what time or occasion it's going to
interrupt you there's always going to be
and i don't want that anxiety in my life
but also if there is a problem and
something's gone wrong then just ring
they can call you yeah ring me just ring
me yeah anyone can ring me and just say
look i've got a problem and then we drop
everything don't we i always feel like
it's the biggest responsibility i have
is to the people that i work with
and if they ring me and they're in
trouble they've got a problem we have to
deal with that that's the absolute
immediate
you always going back to your early
years in football and as you came
through the ranks you you always and
i've seen this in multiple interviews
kind of a little bit self-disparaging
about your own ability
yeah
i just played with brilliant players
didn't i mean if you think about it just
go through the players who i played with
yap stam
you know dennis irwin peter schmeichel
roy k
david beckham cristiano ronaldo dwight
york eric cantona every single one of
them had more talent and ability than i
did
you know just they just did it it was
just obvious around me when i got to
united juice about insecurity the only
time that i ever felt insecure was when
i got to united i got to get at 11
and i joined at 11 and the center of
excellence group and we got retained
every single year but at four teens
where it gets really serious and they
start they sign the scot the school boys
and the outer town lads come in
so all of a sudden you were exposed to
them to beckham to scholes joined at 14
all these brilliant players
and you think how am i going to survive
here i could just i'm aware
i know my own abilities
um and
i had to i had to just do things
differently i was a midfield player then
i was a centre-back then they need to
put right back
you know there is an element of truth in
what carrick has said no one wants to
grow up to be a gary neville meaning no
one's gonna grow up to be a fullback
everyone when they're a kid scores goals
or sets up goals and then you find out
that you're not good enough to do that
and you get pushed back the team that's
what happened with me
i was one position away that was the
last my last hope right back you know i
mean i was out the team if i couldn't
play right back i'd gone from center
midfielders 11 12 year old at united
then sent it back from 14 to 18 and then
told i wouldn't i wasn't good enough by
my reserve team coach to be a center
back at united because steve bruce and
gary palace were there and then i go to
right back so
you are aware that you're being pushed
out of your positions by better players
and that that's your only route to
success is hard work and playing it
right back and trying to adapt to that
and then
it was good enough for me in the end but
you know it's not disparaging i i knew
the game i could organize i knew the
game well
i read the game well
and um
on the pitch i would never ever i would
never give in
so that around me this idea of being
able to organize the team i could see
the game in front of me so i had an
impact i believe had an impact on the
other players that i played with beyond
my talent through my understanding of
the game and making sure that i never
stopped going and we never stopped going
we keep going we just keep pushing
forward so if we're fighting for a goal
you know i always think what's that i
never go into this little level of
granules i've probably never said this
before when people say to me it's the
greatest moment in my life
i say it's the final in 99 in new camp
when we won the treble
but that
i i made a run from right back
i got the corner for the first goal
because i went oh i sprinted over to the
left wing and took the long throw to put
into the box it came back out to me and
we got the corner
it's not an assist by any stretch of the
imagination typifies my career of seven
goals and very few assists i am no trent
alexander arnold or nor even the dennis
erwin
but that that
that you have to find a way to win you
have to just do everything you possibly
can you cannot leave anything on the
pitch you just sprint everywhere you
just do everything and that to me
typified what probably i was that i
could see something in that you know in
terms of how to impact a game whether it
be through impacting someone else by
getting them going and giving them the
ball and get and keeping them at it
um and that's why i think he kept me
there till i was 36 because it wasn't
through ability at the end he kept me
there those 36 just through my influence
and my impact i had in the dressing room
i'm pretty certain of that because it
wasn't through anything that was doing
on the pitch so i'm always
humble around my own ability because of
the talent i had around me
and that's why i get caught on twitter
quite often people will say to me if i
haven't been if you haven't been at
manchester united you've been a job in
right back somewhere like full of my bum
i thought
maybe i've never heard anyone
in a higher managerial position
disagree with the phrase that hard work
beats talent when talent doesn't work
hard
yeah i mean that's one thing i could
never ever i could never ever be accused
of anything other than from the minute i
joined at 11 to the minute i left at 36
manchester united got everything out of
me everything and to prefer the club
gave me everything so we we didn't owe
each other anything
and that's something i'm proud of
longevity is actually probably one of
one of the things that consistency and
longevity being able to consistently
work hard every single day at a good
level of performance and turn up every
single day and be there is underrated
actually and that that's the thing that
to me for surviving at 25 years under
alex ferguson in that environment of
excellence and
demands that he placed on people was you
know it was a great achievement but i
did that with a lot less talent than the
players in the club when was the first
time you realized that sir alex ferguson
was
you re you felt his influence
you felt
his mindset
joe something in the early days it was
the old school
that head teacher not he's not a head
teacher by any stretch of the
imagination but you've got a little bit
of fear that you may be having your
father as well if your father sort of
gets a bit angry with you you know that
little bit of that dominating male
of the 70s 80s 90s probably going back
beyond that was was apparent in sir alex
ferguson that you know you knew when he
walked into the room the room went quiet
that was that presence that aura hit the
boss's ear
and so you felt it straight away
when people say to me sort of how did
you keep coming back every single year
and continue to keep winning what was
the secret of that
it was by his actions and what what he
did i i always remember when i was third
when did we lose the champions league
final 2009 so i'd have been 34 right
near the end of my career
i was doing my um
we played the champions league final on
wednesday we lost
we got back on the friday
from rome or thursday or friday on the
saturday i had to go and pick up my
boots at carrington the training ground
so it was a sunday morning i had to pick
up my boots at current in the training
ground to go to saint george's park
because i was doing my a licensed
coaching badge and it was my final
assessment
and i went in at seven o'clock in the
morning i'd organised to meet with the
caretaker who was basically there on
site all the time to let me in
and i parked on the back
and the his office lights on and he's
there in his chair
i thought oh no i don't want to see him
we just lost the european cup final four
four days ago so i drove back around the
front and went and got my boots and
moved out but he was there sunday
morning half six seven o'clock the only
person in the building with his light on
four days after we'd won the european
cup final and he'd been in his mid 60s
i thought
no one could live with that
that that's the reason he's winning
that's the reason he's because no other
manager
no other leader that i know
four days after that defeat in his off
time in the summer he's in his office on
a sunday morning at half past six and he
didn't know he didn't know i was coming
in obviously and he didn't see me either
i just thought you could just see him in
the distance it was i couldn't believe
it and he just all those sort of
examples of that work ethic
they hit you every single day and he
knew how to tap into here he knew how to
get you no matter who you were in the
dressing room he always used to get me i
would say this but i mentioned in my gra
you could he used to mention my
grandparents what about your
grandparents getting up every single day
putting their tie on the work that they
put in
how they never complained about anything
you know what they must have lived
through obviously in the second world
war and he would say things like that in
his team talks and it would always tap
into me because i used to sit with my
mum's dad and look at his medals that he
had he got during the second world war
he'd had three or four wounds he had
shrapnel wounds in his shoulders that he
could still show me and bits of metal
still in his body and he'd talk to me
about the medals and where he'd got them
from and how he'd been in holland and
how he sort of had to come back and then
he went back over how he married my nan
on one of his returns back
so that used to get me every single time
so when i used to play for united when
you think about what motivates you what
gets you going
and you used to mention say for instance
grandparents and there's that difficult
moment on a pitch where you think we're
struggling here a little bit
and now i think of my youngest daughter
when i'm training what keeps me going to
the end of that training session
i think of silly things
if i don't keep going here someone's
going to get my youngest daughter and
i'll there's nothing going to get her so
i've got to keep going and there is mo
it was my it was my granddad my mum's
dad
i used to think he wouldn't he wouldn't
stop going he came back having been
wounded twice and trapped the wounds
twice and went back out
to fight again
and he had those medals and he would
speak to me about it
and i used to think
how can i stop
but he would he would find that in me
sir alex would push you'd push those
buttons and press those buttons for
someone else it would become something
completely different i'm sure
it might be talking about the father it
might be talking about him going on
strike in the government shipyards it
might be talking about another
experience that he's had but he would
tap into everybody in the dressing room
in some way that would mean they'd find
something
to mean they would never give in and
that's what he's you know his film's
called never give in he never give in
but also the influence he had on others
never to give in through finding
something in them was was incredible
rio talked to me a lot about culture and
the culture that sir alex ferguson said
everest said the same thing having left
football now and working in the world of
business you might must be looking back
on the culture he created yeah and in
some ways
drawing a lot from that in your own
businesses right what what what have you
learned about the importance of culture
because there was a comment
made to me on the podcast that i've
never forgotten which is about sir alex
ferguson's like lack of presence at the
training ground rio said he only came
into the training
training room dressing ground a couple
of times because he didn't need to the
culture was in there yeah and then rio
talked about how then when ria went and
moved on to another club in that same
dressing room players are talking about
how much money they're making and all of
these other things which would never
have happened at united now how does how
does one create that culture
i suppose
being grounded
he was grounded and he believed in the
sort of the work that work ethic was
everything to him being proud being
proud to work hard being proud of the
people around you who work hard
uh being proud of your teammates i used
to say look around the change room look
around i'm proud of every single one of
you but look at each other look at what
you each do for each other on the pitch
and now you can't achieve what you're
going to achieve without each other so
we made us respect each other not
everybody got on in our changing room
but most of us did
um
but he tapped into those things all the
time
it was it was it was non-stop and being
grounded um looking after people little
things like
wendy used to get the charity balls
signed
um and roy keane was like this as well
so when every thursday we'd have 30 to
40 charity balls that we would sign and
then they would go to the children's
charities or the different charities in
greater manchester or in the country
and sometimes you're in a rush aren't
you you're a football player you're
young oh wendy i'll sign him after i'm
in a madras i've got going do my
stretching i've got my massage i've got
to have treatment whatever it might be
that you say on the way in some
poor excuse that you'd give or maybe you
just generally did and there was one day
where he basically i think roy had
walked past wendy she was a little bit
upset and only five players out the 23
and the squad had signed the balls
and roy went upstairs
and said to sir alex it's an absolute
disgrace this has happened a couple of
weeks now
he killed us he absolutely killed us the
lack of respect
to to walk past wendy who was there to
get the charity ball signed and not sign
them for her for him
was a dereliction of duty it was a lack
of respect it's not what you do
we're equal in this football club we
treat each other equally we look after
one another we make sure that we're sort
of compassionate and the idea of not
doing things like that little things
like that
um i think just little things like that
stand out in my mind so now sometimes i
walk into the businesses and you know
what we're like we sometimes walk in on
our phone and we don't say hello to
people because with that immersed in our
own blinkered sort of space
but then i'll walk past sometimes and
i'll realize i've not said hello to
someone i'll go back and say i'm really
sorry and i'll i'll you know i'll say
are you okay and
i do feel like even when in the office
there is no
i sit next to people in the office i
don't sort of have my own gloss tower
yeah i don't i don't i make sure i go
and sit in cafe football in the hotel or
i'll go and sit in the main restaurant
at stocks or at salford i'd just go and
sit in the main office because the idea
that basically we don't he would he did
have his own office and he did his own
space and he did to be fair delegate and
he would keep his but i i don't think
i'm i'm like sir alex in the way in
which i now
look at my business i do believe it's
very different now
um
but he was very the staff loved him
everybody loved him at the club because
he protected them he knew everybody's
name
he asked about the families he knew the
family's names he was really really
attentive he was far better at that than
i am
far better in that than i am but i
probably to be fair mix with my teams
more than he maybe would so
but the work ethic is the thing
honestly
the only thing you can ever do in life
is work as hard as you possibly can and
never give in and he said you've got
that choice every single day really
simple that's it the talent you've got
you just work as hard as you can every
single day and never give in and then
you come back the day after and do it
again and that's it that's the secret to
what he believed because he said the
talent
is his problem
forget talent i've chosen you to be here
so i'm telling you you've got the talent
don't you worry about that bit
what i need back in return is that other
bit which is the the focus the
commitment the dedication to make sure
every single day you get up and you're
here and you give your all and you don't
give in and that's why i think i stayed
where i was because i believed him i
trusted in him and now it's the same if
someone comes into our business
and they've been selected to come in
that's because i believe they've got the
talent or someone in our senior
management team believe they've got the
talent all they have to do in return now
is go for it and give their all and be
enthusiastic and not give in and then
come back after and do it again i keep
it try and keep it as simple as that i
know there's a lot more to it than that
but it is it was that simple for us i
know then there's the tactics then
there's decision making then there's the
sort of concerns all the things that go
with it but
that was the sort of heart i think of
every all the messaging that we got from
him
they almost seem like old-fashioned
values
what you're saying they are it almost
sounds and i'm gonna be honest it almost
sounds like
what the modern day professional culture
might consider to be a little bit toxic
yeah you know what i mean yeah
this this drive for hard work but
i have to say i've never sat here with
anybody that's reached the peak of their
powers in their career that hasn't said
the same
but now if i'm in my businesses
so i don't
things like
i i don't have i'd never work the first
week in january
i think it's the most depressing week of
the year after christmas you've had a
high and then you go back it's dark it's
miserable that first week so i always
take it off but i always give the rest
of our team in the office that i'm
working off as well
so i don't make people do what i'm not
going to do i'm going away i think in
three weeks for five days i said to
everybody in the office don't worry
about the fact you've got 28 days in
your contract those five days you're off
have the last five days off of the
summer then we'll go for it to christmas
also people are flexible working they
can come in monday they don't have to
come in tuesday they can come in
wednesday i trust them to do what they
want so there is an element of yeah i
want heart i do expect hard work but i
also want people to have a brilliant
time and sharing the success that we
have but also make sure that if i'm off
i would expect that they have those
times off as well i wouldn't expect them
to come in
i i don't
hate the idea of a work package that's
got like you've got 25 days holiday you
have to book it in i hate that i hate
the idea of restriction
i hate it i feel like it's bullying you
must sit there in the office i hate it
it's not right it is not right
don't tell people where to sit
how to work you know obviously there is
a direction and there is a leadership
that's needed but i just feel it's
really
not acceptable but now this was
precovered
our office is like to be fair this this
this room that we're in here now so
someone could be sat there someone could
be sat there someone could be sat on the
floor over there with a with a you know
on a laptop that's how it should be in
an office it should always be like that
i think i don't think it needed i don't
think it ever i don't think you needed
colvid to make
modern business
act properly with the teams that they
work with so i i do feel it's very
different than how we were at united
which is old-fashioned value there's
still some old-fashioned values you have
to work hard we have to get the job done
we know that but why do you have to say
that to people
i think people know they have to work
out and get the job done so why'd you
have to say that to them
you're looking to tap into them make
something unique in your business that
makes them want to stay really that's
what you saw you may want to make it
enjoyable
and that can still be enjoyable through
hard work
i think
i think it's quite enjoyable working
i know people that work for you yeah
because you know we've got a got a
colleague that used to work for me that
works for you now and they're all very
very complimentary so that's supported
by that's supported by the evidence that
i have um but you're right i've always
found that the contradiction there is
trust you're saying to your team members
to trust you but you're not trusting
them and trust i feel like has to go
both ways and so and there's and the
other what ends up happening when you
have those in my experience those very
rigid rules is you'll get compliance but
you won't get like motivation and as
you've described it you want people to
be internally driven yeah not compliant
because of punishment yeah and that gets
the best out of people right it's
interesting because um
valencia taught me a lot but around that
time i was with england coaching with
roy hudson um and i'd lived at united
where we were we were fined you know
nunez got sent off last night for head
button
at anderson that's two weeks wages at
manchester united i got fined two weeks
wedges regularly four or five times
it happens football it wouldn't happen
in a normal workplace but we know sir
alex bergson's rules if you violent
conduct or um
chatting back to a referee
you get fined in fact he won't accept it
people think alex ferguson was like get
after the referees but if we actually
got booked
for having to go a referee we would get
fined so very much quite a rigid thing
and then roy hudson said something to me
when i was with england
and i felt those standards were slipping
a little bit one time i can't remember
exactly what it was about
and i said we need some rules
because i had we had a code of conduct
at united i was the player's rep i knew
what the sort of standards were
and he said to me we don't set rules he
said be very careful with rules
uh he said because it's always the
people that you don't want to break them
that break them
i thought it's quite clever that
and
ever since there are no rules there are
no rules in our business in terms of you
must be here you must do this you must
wear that you must you know i don't
expect formality in in dress i expect
people to be comfortable so i don't say
you should wear this or you should be
here at that time or we should we've got
to do that in any part of my bed i don't
create rules anymore because once you
create rules
for start it's rigid i don't believe
it's right and the rules are there
they're unwritten actually the rules of
sort of working hard and turning up and
doing your job all the things that the
rules are there just they just don't
have to be written down um and
you know you see what happens if you
star player walks in
that's breaking because the other ones
that you know we were talking about that
was set in the low standards
it happens if one of the star player
walks in and we need to work with the
players to make sure that they
understand what we expect of them and
the standards we don't need to set rules
because if you set rules and consequence
and punishment
then
it'll be the one that you don't want to
break them and then you're in a big
you know you're in big trouble so it was
it was a good lesson for him and in
football it's very much
a different place than a normal
workplace anyway
it doesn't live by hr rules a football
dressing room it doesn't
it doesn't you know players are still
getting fined
players still get told where to be when
to turn up what to wear
we like it as well
i still like it now actually i i like
actually being told what to do i
actually like it at sky when people say
to me gary we're doing this you know i
like being told what i respond to it
really well because i've had it to be
fair but i've been instructed from eric
harrison nobby styles brian kidd sir
alex ferguson i've been instructed
through the 70s and 80s you could not
live through the 70s and 80s as a child
early 90s without being instructed
because that was the form of leadership
so we still respond to it a little bit
in our own lives but then when i think
about my children i don't instruct them
i like independent thinking i like them
so when people talk about social media
or when people talk about you know i was
sat with someone yesterday who said i'm
fearing my my children were on social
media i i always say to them your
children should get good at social media
really quickly because they have to
they have to they have to be good at it
so my children are 13 years of age now
they bought they're all obsessed with
social media with the apps they're on it
all the time and you know sometimes
we'll say you know that's enough tonight
and you know let's
come off it but i want them to get good
at it
i want them to use it and find out what
information they can trust and what they
can't trust i use twitter now all the
time for my well one
two debate
but also so actually my news my major
source of news is twitter it's my major
source of news in my life it's really
helpful i don't think as a sports
journalist broadcaster i could live
without twitter you're really important
to me so when people say that twitter's
a suspect get off it there are elements
of it that are but that's a really
important thing for me in my life
because i find all the sort of articles
all the sort of opinions
you know all the breaking news is there
how can i live without that it's what i
rely upon to be able to do my job so
when i come off the pitch last saturday
sunday doing manchester united totally
doing western man city and as he managed
to united bid for arnautovic i used to
have to wait till the morning after for
the newspaper 15 years ago our children
aren't like that anymore they want
things instantly they see things quickly
and they don't like to be instructed
we have to collaborate with them
there's an inevitability you're
completely right to social media and the
internet and digital that will actually
i believe as well will serve as a
disadvantage to them if they if they
don't keep up
because you can't think of a profession
these days that doesn't involve
social media or the internet so you're
you know in in an effort to try and
protect children sometimes we actually
cause them a pretty substantial career
disadvantage it should be taught at
schools it should be on the curriculum
social media how to use it
when what to use it for how to get good
at it the dangers the dangers of it it
should be something that's taught it's
got to be more useful to them than some
of the subjects that they're currently
being taught in 2022 yeah
you know when you
this is i mean this is not a nice topic
to talk about because we're both
manchester united fans but through all
you've been through in the era you grew
up in and all of those famous influences
you had that instilled those values in
you
um and even the early initiations you
had in that dressing room from the
senior players and you know i read about
all of that stuff as well when you look
at what's going on at the club today
even though you're not you're not in the
dressing room you must have a pretty
pretty
strong hypothesis as to why manchester
united in 2022 are failing based on what
you experienced
yeah i think
it comes down to a lack of leadership
and direction from the top and vision
and um a deterioration of the sort of
beliefs over a long period of time
i said last night actually that um a
school that's underperforming over a
long period of time and getting poor
results
gets put in special measures by ofsted
and by government
and they're not blaming the kids
it means that the governors it means
that the sort of the head teachers the
people at the top of the organisation at
the school have not basically set the
standards for those children and they've
let the school basically rot and the
results become poor i think that's
what's happened at united
it was a high performing school
the head teacher has left
the board of the governor's left david
gill
and what's happened since is that
they've been replaced with people who
haven't got it and poor standards
have just meant that ultimately over a
period of time there's become an
embedded rot
and that's what's happened and all the
kids the players
look now like they haven't got a clue
anymore and they're getting poor results
i don't believe all those manchester
united players that are on that pitch
are poor players when they came to the
club some of those players i was really
excited by their arrivals
and i've seen players that weren't as
good as them go to other clubs in excel
so the environment the culture
the
yeah the enthusiasm that you need to go
into work every single day i don't
believe has been created by the
hierarchy at the club and then there's
been a sort of a
a lack of investment into the facilities
into the stadium into the training
ground so now tottenham liverpool
liverpool now live people i used to
laugh when i used to go to anfield when
i used to compare it to old trafford i
used to think they can never catch up
they're too far behind
they're just building that second stand
now behind that left and goal where the
away fans sit
and we saw it last night towering up the
main stand now is towering up and it
holds i don't know it holds 20 000.
anfield will be a more modern ground
than manchester united and old trafford
in 12 months that is unforgivable
from to think we're not all taking us on
the pitch
but actually they've overtaken us off
the pitch manchester city are light
years ahead on and off the pitch
tottenham have invested 1.3 billion in
stadium you've been to a tottenham
stadium oh yeah it's out of this world
it's it's uh the best in the world it's
a museum it's the best in the world i
can't believe what i'm walking through
when i see it and yet if you go to their
training ground which i've been to
it's an amazing
brilliant facility
that is far better than carrington where
we moved to in 2001.
we moved to carrington so in 2000 we
moved to carrington we left the cliff
training ground in salford so it's 22
years it's a bit of investment but in 20
years manchester united have not
invested in the stadium they've not
invested in the trading ground that much
and then they've lost
the two main people and before you know
it you've got a club that's really
struggling
and i've said that in the last couple of
years the only thing that i really do
think can change it now is that is is
the ownership and
i say that on here more calmly than i
say on sky sports but it's it's not an
emotive subject anymore it's a very
serious issue there is an embedded rot
at the club
you know that they're walking past
wendy's balls now don't you
do you know what i mean no
is in like signing wendy's balls oh
sorry yes personified for me yeah caring
about values in every single touch point
even the small stuff yeah and so i i was
thinking then i can almost imagine now
those small expressions of our values as
you said they come from the top down
yeah are probably now being missed it's
funny because as fans we look at the
thing we got he's not running fast
enough or blame this player or fred or
does this play or whatever but when
you've when you've worked for me when
i've worked in an organization i
realized that the values the culture
everything starts from the top and if
you bring in great and as we've seen at
manchester united you can bring in the
best stars into a bad culture they'll
become bad performers yeah and um i
always always said in a business context
as well if the culture's strong enough
new people become the culture if the
culture's weak the culture becomes the
new people
it's why i was kept at the age of thirty
three to thirty six in the yeah because
you're a disciple of the course because
because raphael de silva from brazil
comes in i'm the right back that's the
senior right back
and who does he look to
he looks to me he looks to
paul scholes he looks to rio ferdinand
and he sees people that are at the very
top of the game their experience their
end of the careers that's why i looked
at steve bruce and brian robson eric
cantona i had nowhere to go as a young
player i knew i had to do what they had
to do else because they were all doing
it every single day they've been doing
it 15 years
i do feel sorry for the current players
and that won't go down well with a lot
of manchester united fans because a lot
of manchester united fans will say
they're overpaid
and they're chanting it and bluffing it
they're not they're not i know some of
those lads they're good lads if they
were sat here now with me and you you'd
be thinking there's an element of
vulnerability there
there is a lack of confidence
they're crying out for help
i wish they had sir alex i wish they had
roy keane in the changing room with
nemanja vidic and rio ferdinand at
centre-back and peter schmeichel in goal
because if they did
they would grow they would thrive they
would deliver
if the manchester united team today
was david dahir in goal
patrice everett left back
harry maguire at centre-back
with
varane
it was me at right-back in midfield
there was roy keane and michael carrick
on the left was marcus rashford on the
right was jaden sancho
up front was
martial
with
rooney or hughes
those same five or six players that
we're currently saying can no no not not
good enough to play for manchester
united
they would be outstanding if sir alex
ferguson was the manager
if the culture was still there
it's i don't honestly i i that might be
i don't even know what i've just said to
be fair i've not said it before i'm
trying to say
if you surround yourself by those people
who've got those standards who've got
that experience who can cradle you
through the difficult moments like we
were when we were young players when
when people said we won the league with
kids we didn't we wouldn't have won the
league without the experienced players
in that dress room around us and the
guidance of alex ferguson they've not
got that guidance off the pitch and
they've not got that guidance and
comfort on the pitch i used to walk out
in the tunnel
with peter schmeichel in front of me roy
keane in front of him behind me
obviously david beckham always went
behind me but dennis hearing in front of
me i felt safe i was 21 22 23 years of
age i felt safe
i felt comfortable because i knew i was
being looked after by experienced people
i knew that i was wasn't alone these
players go out onto the pitch now they
feel alone they don't feel like they've
got anybody that's where i am a little
bit critical of cristiano
you're the man you're the star
you're the you're the best player in the
world
come on now's not time to be throwing
your arms around now's not a time to be
walking off the pitch
now's the time to make sure you lead
those people but he wants to leave he
wants to go and play somewhere else and
that might happen and you could blame
him he wants to finish his career at a
club that's achieving great things but
i do think he is the only player in that
dressing room that could lead them
because he's the only one that's got the
inbuilt resilience and mental strength
to get through a moment like it won't be
touching him this other than a personal
frustration level the fact that he's
playing a team isn't giving him the
chances the goals the success he wants
but on a point of view of criticism he
won't be touching him he's he's he's
played at real madrid he's played at
manchester united he's won five six
champions league he's one ballon d'or
he's not you can't touch him with the
criticism or words it's impossible so he
can withstand all his pressure and
protect those players on the pitch
that's what i think roy keane did with
us what peter schmeichel did what
cantona did what robson did they
protected us if i took prime cristiano
ronaldo when he came in from portugal
and i put him in today's team
he'd struggle
each struggle i think he really would
struggle without sir alex's guidance
without the patience of sir alex and
carlos kiros who had that patience with
him at the time do you think his career
would look entirely it would look
different
yo you speak to paul gascoigne and asked
paul gasco when he chose tottenham over
manchester united and he says that if
you come to manchester and work with sir
alex he feels as though his career and
his life would have gone down a
different path and that's why i said at
the very start of this interview why am
i like i am i was very fortunate
that i wasn't
in the centre of london at 22 being led
by experienced players who wanted to go
to nightclubs or to bars
i was in manchester
with dennis irwin and sir alex ferguson
and roy keane and mark hughes and brian
robson who don't get me wrong they liked
a night out but they knew also that that
had to come at the right time and they
would be responsible and make sure you
delivered on the pitch
so i i feel blessed and privileged by
the influences that i had in my life we
talk about influencers now in a
different way don't we
but actually we're heavily influenced by
the people that we come into contact
with and that's where your luck comes in
in life because i can't choose who i
come into contact with
in life you know you walk into a
business to take a job you don't know
that there are 150 people in the
business there could be some really good
people in there that influence you well
and make it really comfortable for you
there could be some bad eggs that mean
that you have to have a bad experience
and influence you in a different way i
just got really lucky throughout my
career that i arrived at united when
they started within the premier league
i then obviously had a brilliant manager
i had brilliant senior players i had
good parents
everything was right in my life to
influence me to be what i am today
without that i'm not the person i am i
wasn't gary neville resilient tough
mentally strong
could handle anything
better work ethic than anybody else when
i was 10. i wasn't i was a kid just to
be fair going to school like everyone
else but i had exceptional people around
me i believe that helped me i don't
believe these lads now in that dressing
room have got that around well they
haven't got that around them
i had a thought crossed my mind for the
first time ever this week
and as a manchester united we're going
to go down
well i grew up my birth year was 1992.
so i've only ever known great times at
manchester united pretty much yeah and
it was the first time
that i played out the scenario in my
head that it's not guaranteed that we
return
to being champions it's all i've ever
known yeah and it was the first time
that i started doing the equation of
like how do great clubs fall
and this is one of the years where i've
seen one of the real catalysts is okay
so the brand starts to deteriorate they
lose commercial deals
then
great players like
harland and nunes yeah don't choose the
club then we can't get great talent we
then don't have the money to get the
great talent at an inflated price which
we could have paid in in the first
couple years after the downfall and then
i'm thinking okay so this could we could
there's there's a chance
and i hate to say it because i'm an
internal optimist it's embarrassing but
every year when we do a little school
predictions in my football chat i'm like
we're going to win the league every year
for the last three years i'm deluded but
this was the first time i entertained
the thought that we might it's not
guaranteed that we return
to the club we were um i i
put us in the top four every i did it
last week you know my predictions but
you know something i know full well
we're not gonna finish in the top four
but i have to just because it's the
manchester united inbuilt thing that you
say we're gonna finish in the top four
but that's how our expectations have
dipped as well because we used to say
we're gonna finish top
no i'm convinced manchester united will
return
absolutely absolutely convinced why
it's not arrogance this and it's not
because i'm biased and it's not because
i've gone to watch the club since the
age of five
i've traveled around the world with the
club
for the last 30 40 years
i've
seen the extent of the fan base the
emotion that exists within the fan base
the scale of the club
and it's two the foundations are too
deep
but those foundations were created
because of like generational success
yeah but we had it we had obviously we
had the busby babes periods about busby
then we had 30 years 25 years before sir
alex brought home a league title so
we've had 25 years before that we've
gone through without success manchester
united
um is not going away
it's not going it's too big it's too big
it's too magical it's too good that is
not that is not emotion that that is
just if i i feel very very strongly
about that that is there is an element
of cycle here
that you know we get in sort of our down
period but we shouldn't accept that
because i'm happy to lose football
matches i'm happy to be fourth in the
league third in league sixth in the
league if we're doing the right things
so have we got a work manchester united
should always have a world-class stadium
it hasn't it shows our best in class
training facility it's always our best
in class fun experience he should always
buy the best beam for the best players
in the premier league he should always
have young talent coming through and you
should always buy should always buy
young emerging talent from overseas
it's veered away from all five or six of
its key principles and objectives that
it's always ever had any business does
that then it's in trouble you've got
owners that to be fair and now taking
dividends out of the club they're taking
big large payments in debt out of the
club or interest payments on the debt
out of the club all the money that the
club generates to be fair is not going
back into the club
and it's now come home to roost they
only own 69 70 of the club and they need
a billion quid to be able to fulfill
those infrastructure projects that are
needed their walls are closing in on
them and they do need to do something
big through partnership or through an
investor or through
a sale in the next i think six to 12
months this cannot go on that was a
watershed moment at brentford on
saturday what we were all experiencing
in that stadium and i didn't obviously
know you were in the stadium at that
time but now i know you were and you
said you were just compelled to stay
because you couldn't leave
everybody that i've spoken to was like
i've not seen
too many things like that in 30 years of
premier league
and actually
i never want manchester united to lose
but actually it could have been an
important moment and a big moment
where
you actually start to think like you're
thinking
could we you know people have said could
we be relegated i said last night on
television if we bring poor players in
this next couple of weeks or don't bring
players in
and cristiano does leave which i think
he may
we could finish in the bottom half of
the table
with a 1.25 billion pound transfer spend
in the last eight to 10 years i'm
finishing the bottom half of the table
and so we are starting to think that way
but i've no doubts it's going to return
it's it's it's too big it's too good
it's
fan base is too great it's it's enormous
it's it's i go i've been a i've been
abroad and watched 15 50 000 people
watch us train in thailand and malaysia
and in singapore and i've seen
manchester the passion still for the
club is huge and so it it's still full
now yeah it's just i just get concerned
that if you know there's another
generation that are growing up without
the the experience i had and who are
they going to choose in terms of you
know
we'll lose something yeah we'll lose
some we have to lose some on the way
there was some collateral damage depends
how long we go through this if this is
two decades then that's a whole
generation that never saw what we saw
growing up also city
city have done brilliant things pep
guardiola is a genius the football is
mesmerizing the operation is slick
um
but
i say this because it will bring
you know
criticism from probably some football
fans and certainly for manchester city
fans
it will never
ever be manchester united and that's not
arrogance it just cannot be what
manchester city it can never replace
manchester united in terms of scale and
size it can win trophies it can win more
trophies but it can never be bigger in
scale and size it's impossible it does
not have the roots the history
that it just does not have it manchester
united is two sets
we'll see i'm i'm not i'm not worried
about the long term i'm very worried
about the short term
um what one of the things that people
don't know about you i believe because i
was i'm you know i'm fairly well read on
on what you do but i didn't realize this
is just the scale of your kind of
business portfolio
it's
it's quite honestly mental
i don't do all of the meat the the media
stuff that you do i'm not you know on on
tv all the time presenting football i'm
not in that arena and when i look at
your business portfolio in mind i'm
going this guy does as much as i do from
a business perspective but you're not
you're not
known to the world first and foremost as
an entrepreneur maybe that's the second
thing people know you as a football
legend second second thing will be
entrepreneur and the second thing is you
don't even like the word entrepreneur
not really no i don't
i suppose it's like broadcast i don't
like the word broadcaster maybe it's
like maybe that is an insecurity
actually or a vulnerability
people say to me you're a broadcaster
but i don't feel like a broadcaster i
don't feel like i've earned yeah i feel
like martin tyler
or
um
you know dez lineum they're broadcasters
they're journalists they've they're
experienced they do it i don't feel like
a broadcaster because i feel still feel
young but i'm not young anymore that
really in terms of i've been doing it
now for 11 12 years and same with
entrepreneur
if you always feel there's something a
little bit can i swear
it feels a little bit wanker-ish
a little bit but i think to be fair
probably i should start calling myself
that because i do have there what there
is one constant they're all in greater
manchester um apart from a media career
which can sometimes obviously be in
london but they're all in greater
manchester in salford trafford
manchester city center
and i feel very focused around my
investments in that and some people
would say that's naive you should expand
beyond greater manchester no i'm
passionate about where i come from where
i live and i want to invest back in to
that part of the country so the two
hotels the football club they develop
the big developments that we're doing
the university
um
the project management consultancy all
of them in greater manchester
and i want to continue to do things i
don't think i'll do many more startups
although the overlap is a startup but
just startups are hard do you think
startups are hard oh that's so painful
they're rewarding but the pain i mean
all of mine have been startups right
apart from salford which to face a bit
of a startup it was like eighth tier the
170 fans they're all startups so not one
of them has been sort of a business that
i've bought into which
i'm not sure that that's that's the way
i like it because we can influence them
and we can make them our you know our
culture can come into the sort of
businesses um but yeah i wanted to do a
lot in business but in greater
manchester build teams it's the teams
part of it that gives me great
satisfaction and then
yeah i love the sectors that i'm in
and it's crazy because when i look at
your businesses when i've looked closely
at them you run really
good businesses as it relates to
attention to detail your hotel in
manchester the stock exchange hotel i
have to say
is by far my favorite hotel it's not
even close when i filmed dragon's den
the first year um all the dragons stay
at the lowry
even though it was my first year i was
like please let's take the stock
exchange hotel and i stayed there it's
by far in a way there's nothing close to
it in manchester in my view no and i
have to say some of my so the university
i think is more of a social project to
trying to be more inclusive and sort of
remove the barrier to higher education
the football club started off as a sort
of a more of a social project in terms
of bringing young players through and
believing in young talent in football
like we've been believed in but then i
also have this other side of me which is
i want to raise standards
we wanted hospitality to be the highest
level in manchester and the stock
exchange was my ambition to create the
number one hotel premium hotel in
manchester luxury hotel the same with
the development set michael's which we
hope to be the new number one hotel in
manchester when it's built a new
five-star hotel manchester only has one
five-star hotel in the city center those
lowry's insult but there's like one
five-star hotel
so then some people will throw at me
you know how does that sit with your
sort of social conscience that you've
got these sort of expensive apartments
you've got these expensive hotel rooms
you charge 40 pounds for a steak
and i'm like
i think it's okay to be offended by
manchester
not having enough affordable housing
and also not having
high-class luxury accommodation and
luxury products i'm offended by both
why does manchester all have to be sort
of pigeon-holed into this
three-four-star market so this idea that
in manchester
is that you know and i get called
champagne socialists sometimes and
sometimes get criticized for the fact
that they have a university that is
trying to improve
you know
inclusion and and and and access to
higher education but then oh neville
he's just basically selling developments
you know he's he's selling apartments
for five six hundred thousand pounds
he's he's you know his rooms are 250 300
pounds at hotel football or
stock exchange
but i'm offended by the fact that we
can't raise the standards at sort of the
highest level and the fact that we can't
look after people and make sure that
everyone's got this sort of a house to
be able to live in that's of a
comfortable size and in the area they
want to live so i feel that i'm
um a little bit torn between my projects
in what i feel but i want
high standards in our city i want
manchester
i'm offended that manchester does not
have
five-star
international standard hotels it offends
me that london always has to have these
things or that paris you know why do
people from manchester have to go to
paris or london to experience five-star
hospitality
and service we should be able to get it
in our city so i want to drive
investment into our city
um and raised the standards that was
that was what the stock exchange was
about raising standards of hospitality
and we got to number one which was
really i mean it's but you're right
because if there isn't that supply there
for the high end then the economy is
going to suffer because you're right it
won't attract business it won't attract
um
investment into the city if you know if
and that's you know
i love coming to manchester because i
you didn't pay me to say this but i love
going staying at the stock exchange
hotel it's better than my house
and at the standards there are you know
unbelievable
politics
you've become quite um political
specifically on twitter in terms of
social issues and using your voice to
shed lights on shadow light on things
that you feel like are going wrong in
politics what is the thinking there joe
something i think it's coming look the
thinking is that i don't think
it's not acceptable to be quiet anymore
if you're in a position of influence and
if you're seeing something that's wrong
it's like your stance on the glazes yeah
i think it's got to the point where i
was i was quiet when i played at the
club and to be fair we were winning so
you think well okay winning to be fair
covers everything and then when you
leave you think well i'm gonna second
you know let's let them have time after
alex ferguson but it's got to the point
now whereby
i can't keep my mouth shut on it it's
wrong it is just wrong same with uh with
johnson eventually his own party got to
the same position that i was at and many
others it's wrong we cannot have someone
like that leading our country i'm
passionate about our country are you
ever gonna do politics no i won't do
politics and the reason i say that is
that you know sometimes you have this
idea in your head don't you that you
think could you go in but the reality is
it means that i wouldn't be able to be
as honest as i am on television i
wouldn't be able to do the sky sports i
wouldn't be able to do the media i
wouldn't be able to do my projects in
manchester because i feel conflicted
with different things
and
i don't think i think i'm more
i think i can have a greater influence
in greater manchester
and with my voice in the media than i
would do being an mp for berry south
i genuinely believe that i think i get
caught up and stuck in the tree called
in the mud like everybody else
that's what people say about politics
just go in there you just get stuck
and i don't want to be stuck i want to
be able to try and influence things in
the private sector away from public
sector
and we'll get called a champagne
socialist for it and will get attacked
heavily in the last 12 months
by people from the right side of
the country in terms of you know i
regularly every single day will get
attacked for being a champagne socialist
when i talk about safer into the stock
exchange or i talk about
um you know the st michael's development
and then they say well how can you
be arguing against boris johnson and how
can you be arguing how can you be in the
labour party there's this idea that you
can't be in the labour party and be
entrepreneurial and be successful and
earn money
that the labour party have got to change
that perception
they've got to change that perception
how is it that you cannot be someone who
owns a business makes profit hands that
profit back to its shareholders and to
the teams that you work with create a
great environment for them to work pay
them well
and that you believe everybody should
have an equal opportunity how can you
not be labor and have those principles
because we've been basically
conditioned to think that it's only the
tory party that is good for business and
the labour party has created that it's
so true it's one of the things that's
really made me feel quite
disenfranchised i grew up with in a
labour family that i mean i've never
voted here in my life but in recent
years as i've become more successful in
my career i almost feel a little bit
sometimes by some people not everybody
on the left but some people on the left
that i'm inherently evil because of my
success like i'm inherently a bad person
because i'm an entrepreneur or ceo and
that that pushes you out it almost
pushes you into this middle i'm not
going over to the right but and i want
to belong somewhere so you're completely
right and i don't think that's talked
about enough i was sorry i saw an
interview on social yesterday actually
in the middle of monday night football
and it was an interview it was only
released yesterday it was with keir
starmer and the gentleman asking him
said you know what do you earn and he
said hey 130 000 pounds a year
and he was about to start a line of
questioning
around cair's position on um energy and
the fact that you can afford the three
thousand pounds four thousand pound
energy bills this year
i was offended by that line of
questioning the leader of the opposition
in this country politicians in my
opinion
should be the highest quality
of business people and entrepreneurs to
be able to deliver
the plan that we all want i think that
we need to encourage people to go into
politics
and the idea that the leader of the
opposition was being attacked because he
was 140 000 pounds because he's a labor
politician it's almost like you're a
labor politician you shouldn't take the
mp salary you should almost donate that
to charity and work for like nothing i
mean that's just ridiculous so the
perception of labor and what people
think about labour is that if you're in
labour party you have to be on minimum
wage you have to be a socialist you have
to think like that
no
you can think in a capitalist way but
with some compassion and feel like you
can
be equal with other people and and
spread your wealth and that actually you
can want people to be able to afford
their energy bills and you can fight for
them even if you're in a sort of wealthy
position yourself why can't i or you
fight for people who can't afford their
energy bills this winter just because we
have a bank account that's more than
people would like it to be i i don't get
that
i don't get that i don't understand it
yeah it's a weird thing i i don't get it
we have to change that i think to
perception and that's why i joined the
labour party to think that actually i
can be successful i'm a northern
north for a northern family that have
done well i've earned good money and
continue to earn good money but my
principles where i am now even though
i'm an entrepreneurial
individual who to be fair as profit
making companies
i can be
uh i can be labour i can think
with with a social conscience i i don't
think that's a problem
to me that has to be the future of the
labour party yeah you have to say
because then you're the leader of it
either no no no no no i no
no this is enough i like my life i don't
know i get criticized as it is but um no
i i also
have felt really disenfranchised by the
left that i grew up um feeling part of
for that very reason and i i would love
if anything to to see the next leader of
the party really speak to that and that
would make me feel um
energized again about politics
you talked about being attacked you've
talked about this unbelievable
relentless work ethic you have that when
i say attacked you get attacked every
day on social media but because you've
got a big voice you have it's
unavoidable you've talked about this
relentless work ethic you have and
you've talked about how you had that
moment where you collapsed one day
over the last 10 years our understanding
of mental health and male mental health
has risen tremendously when i was
growing up to have
a mental health issue meant that you
were crazy that's what i thought that
was the stigma we've come so far
thankfully from that perception
what has your experience been with
understanding your own mental health
over the last
couple of decades and have you ever had
a moment where you've gone
i need to put my mental health first now
because
you know other than that collapse moment
where you've experienced anxiety or
depression or these kinds of
ailments
yeah i think that obviously losing my
confidence as a football player being
criticized stopping
having to stop reading the newspapers of
the day
at the age of 24 didn't read a national
news didn't read a tabloid newspaper
from the age of 24 through to the end of
my career why because they were damaging
damaging hell
um if you read something really critical
of yourself in the national newspaper
and the thought then millions of people
are also reading that particularly when
you're young
and you're vulnerable
it impacts you and you lose confidence
and i did lose confidence
i lost form got criticized heavily by
newspapers would read the newspapers and
it would have a direct impact on me
physical impact no no direct impact on
me in terms of how i felt it would drain
me of confidence and then you get you
almost then lose more confidence about
six months this went on for i also at
the time had lost
um i had come out of a relationship um
with someone i'd been engaged to and
been with for seven years so i had two
things going on at once once i'd lost my
form and i'd come out of a longer-term
relationship and at that point i did
feel really low didn't tell anybody as
you would you wouldn't do back in sort
of well what that win
1990
it was 2 000
2000 1990 1999 2024 25 years of age
um made two big mistakes against vasco
de gama played a poor tournament for
england in euro 2000 and it went on for
six months
but went to see a psychiatrist and i got
coping mechanisms i got coping
mechanisms things that basically he
talked to me about about how to put
things into perspective and that dealt
with my mental health issues at the time
and it also helps me to deal with things
that come forward now of a critical
nature when you say you were feeling low
what were the symptoms of feeling low
for those six months not wanting to play
not wanting to take the ball on the
pitch and confident to take the ball and
pass it hiding a little bit
fearing games coming forward anxious
about games coming thinking about my
relationship breakup during matches
which is
unthinkable for me i remember playing a
european game away i think it was either
in anderlecht or somewhere like that and
actually thinking in the middle of the
pitch about my ex-girlfriend and
thinking i'm playing for manchester
united this is not what's going on and
it impacted me in thinking that but then
that happens i'm sure to every single
football player so i knew that at that
point then i needed to see somebody
because i wasn't playing well um he
sucked me against real madrid in the
quarterfinal of the european cup
um and had a nightmare absolute
nightmare um and i thought
i remember we won the league that year
at southampton away
i remember jumping up there's a picture
of me jumping up on the pitch with the
rest of the players and me feeling empty
and not even feeling like celebrating it
i always remember that and it was the
worst league that we ever won
for me
but for others it might have been a
great league but for me i just hated
that league i didn't enjoy it at all i
feel like i just needed to stop and you
know
i felt like i was spinning on a
roundabout and i couldn't get off it
i remember saying that to the
psychiatrist at the time
and they started to put these little
coping mechanisms in place
so if i get nervous before a game think
about what you're going to be doing
later on that you're going to enjoy if
you have a really bad day think about
something simple like did you ask
yourself a simple question like i said
before did you always think you're going
to have a good day every day such a good
question i love that question yeah yeah
i thought i think i've got some pretty
bad days going forward it's like
self-compassion almost yeah that's how i
do that's how i dealt with my dad did i
think that my there was a good chance in
my life that my dad would die before me
yeah i i i was prepared for it
and that's not right but that's how i
dealt with it really simply there was
always going to come a point where my
parents and grandparents were likely to
die before me and i would have to deal
with that
what we can never ever comprehend is
obviously losing someone that's younger
than you in your family we can't
comprehend that that's the unthinkable
that's the one thing if you said to me
that sort of breaks me
um
that you know i think i think would
break me completely but then on the
other side we know that you know my
grandparents literally were in their
eighties
my dad literally was 65 i thought i'd
like i'd loved him to have lived another
10 15 years of of course but he didn't
but i was able to deal with it through
the idea that
he lived his life to the full he didn't
make those changes that i'm probably not
making now he carried on going out with
my sister and the mates till 3 4 in the
morning having a drink traveling to
australia watching her play and
you know living life watching united
every single weekend doing the things
that he loved and you know his life was
taken away at the age of 65. so i could
almost explain that to myself and deal
with it in a pragmatic way
some people say you know some people
close me i've still not dealt with it
five six seven years on because i've not
probably shown the proper emotion and
grief that i should have done through it
but
i feel like i have dealt with it
i feel like i have dealt with it
um
just through being able to put those
coping mechanisms in place
so i always feel we all need those
simple coping mechanisms for others it
might not be the same as me one of the
big things i think of me is definitely
training
so i blew up at sky one boxing day where
i just wrote i always got the sprint to
christmas where everyone tries to get
everything before christmas and then you
just collapse when you stop boxing day
one year the only time i've ever missed
a sky game
uh
everton the hull boxing day i was going
to hull i woke up in the morning i
couldn't get out of bed and i just run
myself into the ground i stopped
training i was eating too much i put
weight on you'll see in the first few
years after sky
and i'd stop doing the things that kept
me well
so training now if i don't train for a
week i feel terrible not just physically
i feel it up here i've got one of those
bodies because i've been a football
player
i know when i've put
i feel every chip
so i can feel it here i can pinch myself
we're all the same as football we had
our body fat
you know once a week we're weighing
ourselves every day because we know
that's a big part of our performance
hydration nutrition weight is a big part
of our performance
and so i know it i've lived it for 15 20
years but then i stopped doing that for
the first five six years out of football
and then you blow up and then you feel
awful you look awful and you've got
people on twitter sending you
you know
jesus you're carrying a bit
you know what i mean
stop eating the chips choose the salad
all those things get sent to you
and you look at yourself in the mirror
and you think
they're right aren't they and then you
start to think oh i've got to change so
you eat a little bit better you eat a
lot better and then you train and
training for here is it just frees me i
i no one likes it i do it first thing in
the morning but once i've finished it
i feel like
i can go and i wasn't doing that so
that's the important part of my mental
health strategy now is just to feel
better buy and the one thing i need to
deal with is alcohol
cause i like a glass of wine
you know like i drink one or two glasses
of wine but colvid i drink one or two
glasses one every night
and then now even now i'm not just oh
i'm at home tonight so for the play at
home so i can't wait it's one of the
greatest moments in my life now tonight
you will get nothing out of me between 7
45 and 10 o'clock so for the plane away
in newport i'm not going but i'm going
to put the feed on on my telly but i'll
have a glass of wine
and it's a magical moment but i don't
need it
so i've got to stop doing that
we'll find out
tonight
liverpool are playing
2015 um your dad passes away when i was
reading
that in your story upstairs and the age
he passed away it struck a little bit
closer to home because um
i
feel like in my life my dad has had a
tremendous influence on me
and i feel like my relationship is not
as close as it could be with him and he
has outlived all of his siblings but in
my view had a much more stressful life
and he's 65
and
i guess the question i had for you is
like
what advice would you give for me
and is there anything that you wish you
had said or done whilst you all behaved
differently whilst that person was here
that you now know in hindsight
um he's the only i don't ring people
i don't speak to don't i don't read my
brother every day i don't text my sister
every day i don't remember every day
around my dad every day three four times
a day the only constant in my life every
single day my dad
um
advice looking after things
what you up to he loved picking the kids
up
so
i made i put his office next to our
house as well so that he has basically
looked after my stuff as well
so
for me he was the constant in my life
every single day and that constant's
gone now and i always say this i've
still got him at the top of my favorites
and my speed dials and i never move him
and it freaks me out sometimes you know
when you're clunky with your fingers and
you press the button just by mistake
because my mum's underneath him you want
to remember and some the odd time once a
year maybe or whatever you press
you know
dadmob
and it freaks me out a little bit
because i think and it makes me get well
up a little bit because i think i used
to ring him every single day three four
times a day just went overnight
i couldn't ring him anymore so that's
the constant has gone so in terms of
advice obviously i don't know your
relationship with my my dad's
relationship with me was so influential
but it would be to
i say that i think this sometimes with
my mum
what excuse have i got not to ring my
mum every single day
i've got no excuse not to ring my mum
every single day for two or three
minutes and ask how she is but i don't
my brother does my sister does but i
don't have that relationship with my mum
i had it with my dad
i had it with my dad so for me just
speaking to him every single day
um i
i wish
you couldn't tell my dad to stop going
out with my sister and the mates to stop
going out with his mates stop going to
the football to stop traveling away to
watch united in europe all those things
that may have taken years off his life
because people people say to me do you
miss your dad
i say
i do
but what i miss most
is what he's missing with my children
and my brother's children and my
sister's little boy
that gets to me because i know how good
he was with him
i know i i saw it for six seven years
it was unbelievable
he adored them and he was starting to
slow down because of them he was
starting not he was starting to make
this used to stay at home to look after
him rather than going out
but he'd gone out for 15 years and he
had a brilliant life did everything
you know he did absolutely all those
sort of things that you you
you read out at the beginning of the 217
caps and the the tournaments were my
sister he was every single one of them
he was every single one of them he
didn't miss a manchester united game i
went i walked out onto the pitch 602
times for manchester united
and i waved at my dad 602 times
there
in that spot every single time or in the
away ended up to try and find him but
that was easy because he was six foot
two and he had a massive big wire you
know ahead of her and i waved him every
single game and if i didn't wave to my
dad i could tell i found my dad somebody
odd gave me away end you're newcastle
away you've seen that the way you sat up
in that top bit
you're like you're looking for ages and
i couldn't settle until i found him
i couldn't settle that was one of the
things like a superstition whether it's
a routine
so to miss that from my life i missed
that idea of he was just there and i
feel comfortable he's there
right i'm okay
dad anything happened
no i know everything's good okay bye bad
spot swimming you know anything it's
that
you know it's that that's
so
maybe speak to your dad maybe
ring him every morning
maybe making me first text
people say you've you've not grieved
that
some people close to me do because
they're wondering because maybe maybe
emma maybe maybe my sister i don't know
what phil thinks about it maybe i don't
know because i just carried on we all
maybe we all carried on
maybe we all carried on
you know i you know on the day that
obviously he died
it was only a couple of weeks ago the
anniversary of it you know i always text
mum you know i miss him so much mum
and
you know i feel that's the one time
where i feel like i connect with my mum
and i don't feel like i can even talk to
my mum on it
because i know sometimes that you know
when
when you've got parents that you're so
close to
and then they've been together
what you then find is my mum's been
unbelievable since
you know my dad passed away
she's absolutely unbelievable my mum but
there are times when we're out for a
meal together or i can see it and she'll
just disappear
and she'll stare into the distance and i
know where she is
but i can i never say
i know where you are mum i know what
you're thinking about i don't feel like
i ever should say that
because it's my mum's space it's my
mum's thought and
you know it's how we deal with it
it's how we deal with it at home we just
know
because i said to her you're right mum
but sometimes maybe they'll say are you
all right yeah i'm fine you'd never get
anything out of her
that's not what you know we don't bring
our problems on to each other
you don't bring your problems onto each
other in our family
that's how we do it but that's not right
we should talk to each other we should
encourage each other but just the way
we've dealt with things but in our
businesses now in a way
we try all the time to encourage people
to speak to make sure that they reach
out
but it's not how we probably act
internally
there's almost a bit of um i i'm
guessing from what you've described him
as a lot of that might have come from
your father
that that or was he a an expressive
emotionally experienced but he had
emotion to be firm i think my mum's
probably less emotional than my dad
really yeah i think my dad's quite
emotional
but again he probably did yeah he
wouldn't
push his stuff on to others i don't
think but you didn't do did you you
don't do no i say the 70s and 80s period
you don't push your stuff on to others
because the parents of my mum and dad
grew up coming out of the world war
so everything in perspective is that
you've not got a problem
you've not got a problem we had problems
back then
so don't you whinge about this
but we know in this generation now
i think have to adapt and change
because there's a consequence to not
speaking about these things there is
there is they stay stored in the back
room and they come out as you know
alcoholism or yeah they do addictions
and anger we've all seen that in people
around us and it shocks and surprises us
you know i've got a couple of friends
who've had issues in the last four or
five years that i would never have
imagined would never have even thought
and you think have i not spotted that
have not seen that
how we're not opened up to each other
about that
it happens
it happened that
in all walks of our life
in all walks of our life so we have to
we have to encourage it
hopefully that's what we're doing here
yeah i hope so
when you know i read that you when you
look forward at your future you kind of
plan in 10-year cycles
so the obvious question is what is what
is what is the next 10 years about for
you because you know i don't i don't
feel like i believe that you're you're
doing what you're doing because there is
some
finish line in sight
it was like we set up a university i
remember the vice chancellor of
lancaster said you do realize you're
entering into something with no exit
yeah
i like the idea of that
no exit
can't sell ua 92 how can we we are you
a92 you can't sell your own university
you can't in my opinion it's what we are
that to me is perfection there is no
finish line thing should go on forever
that you've created so we don't think
short term
i don't think short term i never think
short term but like i say i think i came
out of football thinking the next 15
years were critical to establish myself
in business and to try and remove that
tag of gary neville ex-manchester united
football player that was my target that
was my plan
so whether that be media would that be
in business whatever that might mean
so i'm three years away from that i do
feel like there are bumps in the road
there always are with businesses but i
feel like i'm on track
i need to continue to keep working hard
and focus but i wanted from 50 to 60 to
be laser focused and try and work on one
particular thing and that would be a
result of my previous 30 years in work
the football experience the business
experience the media experience and
bring it together
into something that i can go and do
that's
special i want to do something special
in my life
um special to me not necessarily
especially in sort of you know a greater
sense but special to me
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete and
that has
about 100 calories in total while also
giving you your 20 grams of protein the
salted caramel one if you put some ice
cubes in it and you put it in a blender
and you try it is as good as pretty much
any milkshake on the market just mixed
with water it's been a game changer for
me
i wanted to ask you a question that i've
asked pretty much i think the last 10
guests as well which is if you were to
view your own personal happiness and
fulfillment as a
recipe of ingredients and these
ingredients come in different quantities
but together they make you happy
when you look at that list of
ingredients what do you think is missing
from that recipe for you to be
completely
happy
yeah good question or a difficult
question it must be good if i can't
answer it shut me up on it well i i i
this isn't the question but i i've asked
the last ten guest that exact question
which is you know if you view your
happiness as this list of ingredients
and it's a recipe do i have that's the
problem i remember interviewing tyson
fury and he said i said what what what
does success look like for you or what
does the future last you he said just to
be happy
i thought how simple is that i never
think like that
because
the goals yeah even with football i
never enjoyed it while i was doing it
yeah it's crazy though because i just
felt so intense so i don't feel like i'm
ever assessing what makes me happy or
what
why i'm doing what yeah i i feel like
i'm just like
you're just doing it
yeah
yeah there is an element of that
what makes me happy
watching salford
and winning makes me happy
spending time with my children when
they're in a when they're in their good
space makes me really happy what would
make you more happy that's that's what
i'm getting at is if what ingredient is
potentially missing or out of balance in
that
recipe
i know others would say to be present
more what would you say
to be on the mountain in ski lodge
isolated away from everything
it's weird in it
i don't know i feel free on top of them
i've obviously found skiing after
football feels really sort of basic what
i've just said
you're asking me something really deep
no but there's something profound in
that that solitude yeah solitude and
isolation and
not you'll put that helmet on the mask
on
i'm up on that mountain
and i'm free
the air's fresh and i feel like wow free
from what
from
this
having to talk all the time i think i'm
quite no no no no
no i think i'm tired i think i'm a
little bit tired of hearing my own voice
i think that the next thing that i do at
the age of 50 has to be something that
means that gary neville doesn't speak as
much
[Music]
[Laughter]
so the closing question that's been
written for you from from our previous
guest is
what are some words you've not said to
somebody why haven't you said them and
who should you have said them to
i think it would be to my mum
that
her and her mum and dad
of all the people i always talk about
having the influence on my life
sir alex ferguson i mentioned all the
time i mentioned my dad a lot i
mentioned
eric harrison a lot nobby styles roy
keane all the influences i've ever have
i never mentioned my mum and without a
shadow of a doubt
she's the best person that i've ever met
in my life and her mum and dad
were the best people i ever met in my
life
that's making me a little bit upset
and they were the people who
i think
keep me grounded every single day
because they're just good people
who
do the right things who look after the
family
who put their family before everything
and i don't do that
why does that make you upset
because they put the family before
everything
and
would drop anything for anybody in their
family their immediate family but i
don't
and emma is similar
emery's similar
they're far better people than i am
i feel that you know i mean i never tell
them
because they
that traditional
you know they do their job they get up
they work they look after their family
their responsibilities to their family
whereas
you know i'm
floating around
so yeah it would be that i think
for them to know that that i i don't
take it for granted i understand the the
importance of of that in my life and in
our lives
the most i've ever grieved in my life
was when my mum's dad died he was the
first person that had ever died i was i
was looking for my grandparents i was 30
and my mum's dad died and i came home
two days after my honeymoon
started he died two days into my
honeymoon and i came straight home i
didn't even break i just got on a plane
from the seychelles
because i had to
because he deserved that he deserved
that sacrifice for me to give up the
honeymoon and emma
was fine with it
because he had such an incredible
influence on my life
gave up all his time for me took me
everywhere
cooked for me was there three four
nights a week
i didn't need to do that
so there those those three people
and there are there are others obviously
but i think those three people and you
know
emma is very similar
gary thank you so much thank you um i've
watched you for my entire life on tv as
a huge united fan growing up um and then
obviously even to this to this day on
the overlap and what you do across
broadcast television and i i think it's
amazing and i i've after this
conversation i figured out why you've
managed to sort of grace so many
different industries and reach the top
in all of those endeavors um and it's
because of that those the set of values
that were instilled in you and that that
you clearly exude today your
relentlessness your focus on hard work
and all of these kind of old school
values which i think are a little bit
lost in our generation thank you for the
inspiration thank you you've inspired me
so tremendously and your vulnerability
and your willingness to be
open in that regard i think is going to
create a better future in many respects
from for young men that are that are
driving towards their ambitions and
young women but also as it relates to
politics and what's going on in our
society so you're in a very important
person and it's unbelievable that a
manchester united um
a manchester united right-back has gone
on to do all of these things but it's a
huge inspiration for me and many many
people that are listening i'm sure thank
you so thank you huge huge honor i have
to say that no one wants to grow up to
be gary neville
quick one we have a brand new sponsor on
this podcast which i'm very excited to
tell you about they're a brand called
blue jeans by verizon and they are a
video conferencing and collaboration
tool that has changed the game for our
team so i'm so glad to be working with
them because as you know one of the most
important things for me is when we have
a sponsor it is part of my world it is
part of my life it is part of my
companies as someone who's on calls
pretty much 80 of the day building my
businesses and speaking to my teams all
over the world it's the guaranteed
security that differentiates blue jeans
from all of the other options that are
out there in terms of video conferencing
their enterprise grade security means
you can protect your organization from
malicious attacks and establish real
trust with everyone that joins your
meeting and that is something there are
so many things that make sense and make
blue jeans um a better option than the
sort of competitors out there and i'll
be talking about all of those aspects
those features and the reasons why i use
blue jeans in the coming episodes if you
want to check it out you can head to
www.bluejeans.com
to learn more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]